hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar maximize your variant knowledge
using the human gene mutation database
hgmd professional
i am jennifer woods of lab roots and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by kaiogen to learn more visit
kyogen.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
ruth burton phd
field bioinformatics application
scientist
kiogin digital insights
dr burton you may now begin your
presentation
hello my name is ruth burton and i work
for car engine as a clinical application
specialist
and today i'm going to talk to you about
our database
the human gene mutation database and how
it can help you to understand and
interpret the variants that you have
so what is hgmd
well a good way of answering that
question is in the statement below so
does this human germline mutation cause
disease
and if that's the sort of question
you're interested in answering then hgmd
is a very good place to go and this
database is an expert curated database
of human germline mutations
and all of these mutations come from
peer-reviewed published journals
and we have a saying at carjan that if
it's not published it's not in hdmd
so an important point to note is that
this database contains germline
mutations only no somatic mutations
and one of the things we pride ourselves
about this database is that we use
expert curation to ensure the highest
quality and consistent consistency of
all the information we have contained
within it
so just to give you a brief history of
hdmd database and how it was developed
this was originally established by
professors david cooper and michael
korats based in cardiff university
and initially it was intended for the
study of mutational mechanisms
and data was sourced from a range of
peer-reviewed scientific and biomedical
journals
and the original public version
contained about 10 000 variants across
600 genes and this was and still is made
freely available from cardiff university
and i'm going to show you that later
during our demo and this has been
available since 1996
but quickly this database expanded to
become the sort of main database for any
mutations that cause human inherited
diseases
and our current version which is now the
2021.1 version and this is of our
professional version contains over 3
million variants in nearly 13 000 genes
so we've gone a long way since 1996.
now back in 2016 cardiff university
entered into a commercial partnership
with kaijan and we've become the
distributor of htmd professional ever
since
now because we've got these two
different terms hdmd which is almost an
academic free database and htd
professional then i'm going to show you
both through both of them throughout the
talk and throughout the demo so that you
can understand the differences between
the two
now there's lots of different uses for
hdmd
and
i'll sort of go through these one by one
and again show you some of them in the
demos later
there's
a simple way you can use it you can just
have a variant that you're interested in
and you can look it up and you can
search by
your hgbs nomenclature by a db slip
identifier or just by a chromosome
chromosome or location
and
this will show you
whether your variants in htmd and
particularly this is used for when
people are interested in detecting
variants or understanding variants that
are in rare diseases
another simple use case for htmd is if
you've got a particular gene of interest
and again i'll demonstrate this in a
moment and this is where you can search
for a gene by its name its description
its location or even the transcript or
omin
entry
you can also use sort of a phenotype
search as well to help you understand
your gene in a bit more detail and i'll
go on to show you that again a bit later
this is an ideal tool to
or an ideal way to really understand the
mutational landscape within a gene and
whether the new mutation that you found
is perhaps in a in a hot spot contained
within that gene of interest
now if we're thinking of a perhaps a bit
of a broader application
another option is actually to use htmd
for panel design
and this is where perhaps you're
interested in designing perhaps a panel
for your sequencing experiments and you
want it to have genes that are relevant
to the disease that you're working on
the type of patients you have in your
cohort or perhaps a range of clinical
symptoms that your patients might have
and i'll go through perhaps a few
examples of this but really if you're
interested in panel design you're most
likely to be doing those phenotype
searches or gene or gene searches
just to come up with those genes of
interest
another and perhaps less sort of
commonly discussed use case is to help
help um
you improve either your um
own bioinformatics pipelines or perhaps
to improve sort of a machine learning
model that you might be developing and
these sort of use cases typically use
the downloadable version of our database
so the one i'm going to show in the demo
is our online version but we also have a
downloadable version as well where all
the different searches that i'm going to
show you can actually be downloaded as
tables that you can query and integrate
yourself into your own application
and i've got a few examples in a couple
of slides time where we can discuss sort
of the advantages of using hdmd in that
way
and final example that we have
particularly here in the uk where i'm
based
is
genomics england use hdmd to help them
understand the variants that they've
come across
during their large-scale population
screening program and this is where
again they've been using the
downloadable version of hdmd they've
integrated it into their pipeline and
they're really doing a combination of
tying together searching for genes
mutations phenotypes and actually having
a much more high throughput approach to
understanding the variance that they're
seeing and this is particularly
important when you're
i'm working on you know a large number
of samples and you've got a lot of um
variants that you want to understand in
in one go
so this table just shows you a few
different examples of how hdmd can be
helpful and i'm hoping that during the
rest of the talk and during the demo
that i'll provide a few more
points that perhaps will help you in
in your
studies
so just to go into a bit more detail
about why
um
uh
machine learning
isn't and artificial intelligent ways of
creating databases
aren't really
as perhaps
useful as they might seem on the surface
and why actually having a team of expert
curators
like we have at hdmd to actually
input the information into our database
can be beneficial
now the first point in my table the
speed of curation is definitely where
machine learning or artificial or
artificial intelligence methods win out
over expert curation because expert
curation is definitely slower than doing
it in an automatic process
but when we actually look at the quality
of the data that our experts curate this
is
far in excess of something that's an
automated process
and that's really because you actually
have phd or
md qualified people
reading the original publications
and following a very strict protocol for
curation
and so the quality of the data that they
extract from the publications
is really highly um
improved and more consistent than
something that's just extracting things
automatically from a published piece of
information
now because we've been able to really
ensure the high quality of data that
goes into hdmd this means that there's a
much lower level of noise in the data
so this means if you search for
something in hdmd the result you get
back is going to be accurate and you're
not going to have to look at those
search results and check that they make
sense
we've actually been able to identify
some published errors in pieces of
literature and a common example of this
is where we've corrected some of the
hgvs nomenclature errors that we found
when we've been reading and curating
these publications
another way that we've been able to
really ensure that we can improve the
quality and reduce the noise in the data
that we have in htmd is to normalize to
a specific gene model
and this means that it allows us to
compare across
different
perhaps genome builds or information
from different sources and make sure
that when we're talking about a mutation
we're always talking about the same
mutation so if that mutation is
mentioned in different publications we
know it's the same one and that again
comes back to that thought about
reducing the noise in the data is you
don't want to return a search think oh
wow this invariant's been seen loads of
times before and actually find that it
hasn't these are just errors in how the
curation process has been been done
and thinking about errors we can also
minimum minimize some of the artifacts
that can be seen in mutational databases
and
one example here is where we we found a
variant that had um
four possible predicted mutations and we
were able to verify the correct mutation
and make sure that was the one that was
added to the database
so we found that there's
lots of um ways that having hdmd
expertly created
really helps
and we've also found that having the
downloadable version can actually help
if you are interested in using
machine learning approach or an
artificial intelligence approach
approach to your own pipeline that
having that downloadable version
of hdmd and incorporating it in that can
really help
i've mentioned that there's two versions
of hdmd the public version and the
professional version now apologies if
the text on this is a little bit small
but um i think the take-home message is
that there's quite a lot of ticks on the
professional version and slightly less
ticks on the public version
and what i'd like to draw your attention
to is in the top half of the table in
fact of both tables you can see that the
features relate to searching so you can
search in both you can search in the
public version and you can search in the
professional version and that's really
what we want to enable with any database
this has got to be easy to search
now
in the professional version you get
slightly more ways of doing your your
searches so you can search by
for example references you can insert by
chromosomal location you can search by
refseq transcript so there's more ways
of getting that information out in the
professional versions
but both versions allow you to search
the other main difference and this is
now where i'm looking at the second
table
is in the sort of information you get
out and how it's sorted in the
professional version we tend to have a
little bit more flexibility so you can
sort your mutation by location you can
sort it by phenotype you can sort it by
author and you could even sort it by the
year in which a publication was
presented or published
so
both versions
are really helpful
but there's different different levels
of information available in both and
hopefully during the demo i'll try to
clear up some of the potential
misunderstandings between what you can
do in either and show you the
differences between the two
now let's talk a little bit about how um
the hdmd database categorizes mutations
so
in h both in hdnv professional and in
the academic version our mutations are
categorized into the following classes
so i'm starting at the top of the slide
and i'm looking at the first category
which is the disease causing mutation
and this is perhaps the most interesting
category because this is where we know
that disease sorry a variant is
causative of a particular disease or
disorder
and we have evidence for that in
published literature
the second
category and working clock right
clockwise around the circle
is where we might have a likely disease
causing mutation and this is where there
is some evidence but perhaps
slightly
less concrete that the mutation is
causative for a disorder
and then working round the circle we
might have a in vitro or in vivo
functional polymorphism
we might have a disease-associated
polymorphism
and we might have a disease-associated
polymorphism with functional evidence
or we might have a variant that is a
frame shift or truncating variant so as
you can see a lot of effort has been
taken has been placed into actually
categorizing those mutations and so
particularly when you're looking at the
professional version you'll be able to
see at a glance the relevance of the
particular variant that you're looking
at
so let's expand on those varying classes
in a bit more detail
so as i said the disease causing
mutation is where we actually have
literature evidence
of that variant being causative
the slight question mark is where again
when we've been reading the report the
author has indicated that there may be
some degree of doubt now i think this
category really highlights the advantage
of having a person reading the paper
rather than a machine learning algorithm
because this is where you can actually
interpret the text that the author
themselves have written and actually
help their
their judgment to be
moved in and will help us to populate
that in our database
now one of the fair variant types that i
didn't talk about in the previous slide
is shown at the bottom of this slide
here and that is
shown by a gray
r symbol
and this is where we're able to retire
variants from hdmd so while our database
grows over time we do review the content
and make sure that if we find an
erroneous entry or just that
the record has become obsolete we are
able to retire that
variant or that entry and so we're able
to ensure the quality
of the database as it develops over time
so in the next few slides i'm going to
show you some screenshots of hdmd
and show you some of the search
capabilities
so here we can see that we can search by
gene simple
and in the lower portion of the screen
you can see the hdmd professional option
and i'll show you that live in the demo
so um i won't highlight too many too
many um sections here but just to say
that the gene search option is available
in both versions
when you do get the results of your
gene search in the public version you
get um
just you know the gene symbol you can
see the chromosomal location you get a
description of the gene name
and you can
see the transcript id
in the professional version you will see
an expanded version of the gene symbol
so perhaps if there's alternative names
that names that the gene is also
described against and you get a more
in-depth gene
description and you're also able to link
out to refseq so again slightly more
expanded possibilities in the
professional version but you get results
returned from both from your gene search
when you
click on the results of the
gene view search in the public version
you can see the mutations and how
they've been categorized and you can
click on a link to get more details on
those mutations and i'll show you that
live which i think will make a little
bit more sense
in the hdmd professional version it's
very similar but remember this is a
slightly more updated version so you
tend to get more mutations returned and
you also get their class as well so
you're able to see straight away the
impact of your variant or the variance
in a particular gene and in this case
as shown in the slide at the bottom of
the screen you can see the number of
variants are actually disease causing
then when you actually view the results
here we can
see in hdmv professional
the um
sort of breakdown if you like of of the
results and you can see the um
individual pieces of literature that
have been curated
you can also see
the phenotypes
and you're able to see um where um the
different um
um
uh where the protein is often located so
it's almost it's like it's cellular
location and
it's sort of ontology type so
again
you get results from both the public
version and the professional version but
if you're using the professional version
then the granularity of the information
returned is greater
now as i mentioned at the very beginning
you can search by lots of different
terms in htmd and we've looked in detail
about the gene level search options but
you can also make a very specific search
and look at an individual mutation
and if i was thinking about hdmd in the
database i would say that the mutations
themselves are really the cornerstone of
the database and all the information
links to that this mutation page because
that is what we're interested in is
understanding the mutations that we have
in our sample so when you get down to
the mutation page view this is where
you're looking at the core of hdmd and
whether it's in the public version or
the professional version
this is where you're really able to
understand the impact of the mutation
not only
at the gene level but also at the
functional level as well
and when we come to the come to the live
demo then i'll show you how pieces of
information within this view really help
you to understand
the potential impact
of your mutation
and we can see some of that information
now in this screenshot from the
professional version so you'd get a full
list of all the references where this
mutation has been
published you would be able to see lots
of variant details and link out to
resources such as the ucscg number adder
browser
you can also see the variant in
different genome build versions so you
could convert your variant to hg19 or to
hg38 and this really helps because often
data has been built up over time and
might have been annotated against
different genome builds
you can also see information about the
amino acids
within the gene of interest where from
where your mutation sits and this is
really valuable for when you're trying
to understand the impact that the
mutation has not only at the gene level
but also at the protein level
and so we can see in the table in the
bottom right hand corner a list of
um sort of a well a pilot really of all
of the amino acids
across different species and we can see
where your mutation sits and we can see
how that region has been conserved
across these different species
and this
sort of alignment can help us to
understand the potential impact of a
mutation
occurring at that location
in the lower left hand corner we can see
some results of the unsilico prediction
tools
and these are helpful again for
understanding the impact of the mutation
at the protein level but also if you're
interested in classifying your variant
using the
acgm classification criteria many of
those rules rely on in silico prediction
results
now as i said we can also search by
mutation at um
at uh
at that level as well
and an easy way would be to use the hdmd
accession number if you know that when
we come to the demo i will show you a
few different options for searching here
for your um the mutation that you want
and one of the um the ways that i quite
like doing it is even just to search and
browse for different mutations perhaps
if i'm particularly interested in
looking for
new mutations that have been added
recently or for looking at particular
phenotypes but we'll go through those in
the demo so you can see how this screen
would work in in a real situation
now here we see a screenshot for
phenotype searching
this is again a really useful tool and
it allows you to actually understand
what genes might be related to a
particular phenotype and where if you're
interested in a particular
type of disease or you have patients
with particular
disorders in this screenshot we're
seeing um hearing loss as a as an
example then you can use that as a
search term to actually find genes that
are related or where we've seen um
mutations that occur in those genes that
then cause or impact
those clinical phenotypes and this is a
great way if you are interested in
making a very um
tailored panel to find those genes that
are relevant to the phenotypes you're
interested in
now again i'll hopefully show you this
section in the demo but you can also
search by reference so if you wanted to
check for a particular
publication or if you just wanted to see
if a particular publication contained
any other mutations this would be the
best way to do it is you can search by
the name of the author you can look at
pubmed you can even as i said at the
very beginning look at the year in which
the journal was published so again it's
a good way to start to build up a
picture about
variants or genes that you're interested
in and to start off at the at the
publication level i think this um also
helps us to understand exactly how hdmd
was created
obviously as i mentioned earlier it's
sort of cornerstone is looking at those
mutations but we get that information
from the literature and so you can begin
to see how all of these different
sources tied together by
doing a few literature searches and
understanding the breadth of information
that's contained within hdmd
now one of the search mechanisms that i
find most useful and i think is commonly
being used now
is the batch search and imagine you're
in the situation where you've
done some sequencing and you
have got a vcf file containing a list of
variants perhaps perhaps you're
interested in understanding a rare
disease that you've not seen before and
you haven't really got much uh clin
many clinical details about the about
the sample and where it came from one of
the things you can do is just upload
that vcf file
into the professional version of htmd
and again fingers crossed i'll show you
that in the demo but that allows us to
then just look at those variants search
within hdmd and see have you seen that
variant before and then from then there
fingers crossed you'll be able to
understand more about the variant and
then more about the patient and the
sample from which this file came from
and so this is a really great way to
really hone in quickly and identify
those key important variants because
obviously if a variant's been published
before and it's in htmg and that's going
to really help you speed up your
understanding of that result
and another tool that's also useful is
our advanced search option and this
again is just available in the
professional version of htmd and i'll
again show you this during the demo and
this allows you to do something really
simple like put in a gene name and then
see all of the variants that are
contained within that gene broken down
by their literature their original
literature source by the mutation type
and
also to see the impact of those variants
and i think again when i have done this
search this really helps me to
understand um the range of mutations
that are present in a particular gene
so now i've talked a lot about showing
you some of these features in a live
situation so i'm going to pause here and
then switch to the
live software
so i think i'll finish here for a few
moments
so you should now see on my screen the
two versions of hdmd that i've been
discussing during the slide part of our
presentation today so
currently this is hdmd professional
and we've also got the free
academic version of htmd
so as promised during our earlier
discussions i said i'd show you some of
the ways of using hdmd and the different
search options
that we have available
live so i'm going to give that a go now
so i'm going to start off with doing
something very simple
and that is just searching for a gene
so i'm going to paste in a gene here
oops
and i'm going to search for gene symbol
and i'm going to press go
and
as
as we would have hoped as you would have
expected we get a result returned so we
get the gene symbol again
we get the gene description and we get
its location
if we wanted to find out what mutations
were present in this
gene we would need to click on this
hyperlink and that would take us to
the um
sort of the overview page where all of
the mutations are listed out and so here
we can see in tgfb3 we have 19 mutations
and they're divided into different
categories so we have missense on
nonsense mutations splice mutations that
fall into splice sites
mutations that fall into regulatory
regions
and then four
variants that are small deletions and we
can get these mutations by clicking on
these links here
but before i actually start looking at
these mutations let's compare the result
that we've got in the academic version
with the same search in the professional
version
so i'm going to go to the gene section
of htmd or the gene section of the
online version of hdmd
and i'm going to put in the same gene
and i'm going to want to have a gene
summary so i'm going to submit my query
and we in this instance get taken
straight to a very similar looking page
as we've just seen in the academic
version
but here we can see we have 51 mutations
being returned
instead of in the academic version 19.
these 51 mutations are again broken down
by the different types of mutation
but also in this instance by their
variant class
so we can we talked a lot about this
during the presentation
and so here we can see we've got 30
variants that a disease causing and 21
variants that are likely to be to be
disease causing and we can click on
those by clicking on those links
let's switch back to the academic
version for a moment and actually look
at some of these mutations in more
detail so here for example i might be
interested in these two mutations that
fall into the splice sites i can click
here and i can see those mutations
in a list
so there i can look at the two mutations
i can see the phenotype that they're
associated with and i can also view the
references so the actual
primary source of information that was
used
to add this piece of information to the
knowledge base
if i'm in the professional version i can
also look at those
six
well in this case we've got six
mutations
and i can see them listed out
i've got the hdmds session ids i can see
the hgvs nomenclature and i can also see
the variant class so that's really
helpful because i can see which variants
are likely to be disease-causing and
which variants have been
have for which we have evidence that
they are disease-causing
i can see the reported phenotypes and
again i can see the literature
we also have this extra information
column
present in the professional version
and this can be really helpful because
if for example it does vary a little bit
by variant to variant but here we can
see
the
location for hg38
the location for hg19 and here we can
see that this variant has been
classified as a vus according to the ac
mg classification criteria
um again you know other variants will
have other pieces of information here
we've got a link to an entry and dbsnp
and here we've got um
a sort of a comment where we can see
that this is an exon for um skipping
event
or causes an exon for skipping event
we can also click on any of the
links in more detail to actually go and
look at those mutations in more detail
so if i wanted to look at this top
mutation i could just click on it here
and that would take us to the mutation
entry itself
and so this is a really um
you know
good
um parts of hdmd to be looking at
because it really is a sort of the core
fundamental
part where you can see any extra
information available
you can link out your ucsc genome
browser
and you can see more details about the
variant and we'll look at that and in a
little bit more detail when we start to
move on to the next
searching option and that is really to
use uh
the um the way the mutation has been
described to search for it
now if you had the accession number you
could go straight to here and search for
a mutation but you could also search by
its hgvs nomenclature so let's try that
let's copy that in
and make sure we switch to say that
we're searching by hgbs and then submit
our query
so here obviously this nomenclature is
used across a range of
values across a range of different
different type um
different gene types but here we can see
that mutation in tgfb3 and again we can
start linking out
to the mutation result
and this is for this mutation we've got
a lot more information available so we
can actually um
not only see the variant and where it
sits in the reference sequence so we've
got the reference and alternate angles
being displayed here
we can also see
some of the other sections that i was
discussing with you on the slides
earlier so here we have an alignment of
all the amino acid sequence this is
particularly important because
we can see the conservatory how how
conserved the region is around the
mutation and this can help us to
understand how
what the impact of such a mutation could
be and whether um it falls in a very
conserved region this is across a range
of different species so here at the top
we have humans and further down i think
this must be an alligator and we've got
cow and and so on so again
a really nice additional piece of
information
as we were looking at in the slides on
the left hand side we have the results
of in silico prediction tools so here
oops we've got sift we've got polyphen
concentration taste mutation taster
mutation accessor predictions
um
and we've got the results of the things
like the cad score and these as i think
i mentioned in the slide section earlier
will be really useful if you were trying
to sort of classify your variant
following the acgm criteria
so this is the mutation page and almost
this is like the primary um
piece of information so sort of the end
point of most of your searching
so
while you can
search on the gene level and on the
mutation level it's this
part of the software that you're really
aiming towards and most of the pieces of
information will link back through that
identifier
um to this to this endpoint
if you wanted to do a bit of a more
broader search perhaps you didn't have a
gene of interest and you didn't have a
mutation that you're interested in but
perhaps you were more interested in some
of the clinical phenotypes or symptoms
that a patient might be exhibiting then
it's also possible to use those in hdmd
as search terms so here if we go back to
the academic version we can switch from
our gene level search into our disease
and phenotype level searching i can type
in a phenotype
and i can click go and it lists out all
the genes that we have in our database
in hdmd database where there is a link
between the gene
and the phenotype
so if i wanted to make a short list of
genes where there was an association
association between the gene and bifid
overlap this would be a good way to do
it
by using the phenotype search
we can do a similar
similar type of search in the
professional version so let's go to the
phenotype section and type in the same
phenotype and see what type of results
we get so make sure we switch to
phenotype and click submit
again we get a nice list of genes out we
can see how many mutations there are in
each gene so we can see this
met
um s
um ii gene would be a good one to choose
if we were making a panel because it's
got quite a few known mutations in
already and we've got an extra gene so
this um
fbx011 gene wasn't present in our
academic version so this has probably
come from a recent addition to the
database
so again we could be thinking i'm
interested in a certain phenotype let me
find out from hdmd what genes might be
associated with it so that i can go on
to make a panel
but perhaps you're not interested just
in like one phenotype you might be
interested in a range of phenotypes and
we can search for more than one entry at
a time using the phenotypes search
and one of the nice things and i'll show
you how this works is that you're able
to use um
boolean
operators
so here i'm typing in five different
phenotypes and i've prefixed all of them
with the plus symbol and this means that
i want to find or i want to see if
there's an entry that contains all five
of those phenotypes and so this is a
very specific search and i'm expecting
to get a very specific answer
and
and as you can
you might expect that's what i do get i
get one result and i can see that there
is one mutation in tgfb3 where all five
of these phenotypes are present
so that's a very specific way of
searching
i might be thinking of something a bit
broader though and i might be thinking
well i am interested in all of those
five phenotypes but i don't need them to
be all contained in the same case or in
the same gene
i i might have patients where they have
these phenotypes but they might have
other phenotypes as well or only contain
a subset of them so again i'm using the
same five search terms but this time i'm
putting them in inverted commas and so
i'm looking for instances where any of
these five occurs so this is almost like
the complete opposite this is a very
broad way of searching for phenotypes in
htmd
and so i'm hoping fingers crossed to get
more than one result and actually i do i
get 855 results so here there's a very
big list of genes that
could be related to those five
phenotypes and they've all been searched
for as individual terms
so
when you're using the phenotype way
you can
do either a very specific search by a
single phenotype you can do a very
defined search by using the boolean
operators and combining multiple
phenotypes together or you can search
for any phenotype combination that
you're interested in there's also a
different way another way of using the
phenotype searching and that's just to
browse them and so you might have
perhaps guessed that a lot of the
phenotypes and genes that i'm interested
in during this demo what uh are
associated with the let's ds syndrome so
i could just think oh let's see if let's
see what's what phenotypes we can and
genes we can see
in
in hdmd for alerts to years
so i can browse by all of them for the
letter ow
and
i won't go through all all 12 of the
pages because i do know that the ones
i'm interested in are on page eight and
here i can see all of the lowercase
syndromes listed out here
this is i i thought this was quite a
nice view because you can see how
it's been described in different ways
there's lots of different types of
leucias there's some with marfam right
syndrome
and there's some with other things like
this ulcerative colitis so
there's quite a broad range of
different phenotypes that are contained
within the broader context of lowest
yields
now
i can actually search for diseases in
both versions of the software so i can
go back to my
academic version i can look at lots dies
and i can say disease or phenotype and i
can click go and that gives me a nice
list of genes and phenotypes so if i
wanted to make a targeted panel or
perhaps a virtual panel from whole exome
or whole genome sequencing where i would
just target the genes that are
known to be associated with ds this
would be a good list a good short list
of genes to start with
i can also do something very similar in
the professional version and so i'm
going to again
just type in my disease
i want to look for phenotypes and i'm
going to click submit
and then we get a very similar list but
you can see that we do get more
information from the professional
version so you can actually see the
number of mutations that are associated
here and so we can start to get a feel
for the real key genes that should be on
the on the panel and
ones that we might want to investigate
further
but again both the academic version and
the professional version are both good
for searching at the phenotype level
so we've had a look at searching sort of
at the gene the mutation the phenotype
level so
instances where we know something about
the sample that were or the type of
samples that we're interested in
another way of searching in the
professional version of htmd is to
search by reference
and you can do a very simple search if
you've just got an author that you are
interested in you can just
add this to the search field
search all fields and submit query
and this gives us this paper again we
can see in in this view that this paper
contains a key variant a disease-causing
variant and i think when you're looking
in
um hdmd we always have to think that
that is the key piece of fun the
fundamental piece of information is that
mutation and the impact it has and we
keep coming back to this so again we can
go back here we can look at that hdmd
accession id and we can look at the
mutation that has been described in that
reference
one of the nice things about searching
for references is that you can also see
how many um
[Music]
publications are actually um
how many times a variant has been listed
in an individual publication and so you
can sort of check that variants um
aren't being double counted if you want
to look at sort of frequency of
occurrence so here we can see that this
instance is a primary literature report
so again very nice nice way of
you know being sure that we're confident
that we know
what we're actually viewing
at any point any of these links so if we
wanted to go back and see if there are
any other interesting references
associated with this gene we could go
back and look at the gene level
information
which is shown here
so
and one of the things i perhaps forgot
to mention earlier about the gene level
description is that we can also see find
out a little bit more about this gene
and where it what is in where its
involvement is
is we can actually see um
the
location and the go terms associated
with what this gene is involved in
so
um if we wanted to sort of think about
the types of clinical phenotypes we're
looking at or what pathways might be
involved in this
section here at the very bottom this
gene ontology for tgfb3 can also be um
really helpful
so it's worth when you're looking at
hdmd not just to
focus in entirely on to the
mutation level information but also if
it's a gene that perhaps is a bit new to
you to look at the gene level
information available that's available
as well
so we've sort of looked in quite a lot
of detail about these first three
options and the reference option
now we're going to move on to one of my
sort of more favorite sections of hdmd
and one that i use most frequency
frequently and that is the batch option
batch search option and the reason i use
this a lot is because
i often tend to be finishing my
secondary analysis and i end up with a
um
after doing all my sequencing work and i
end up with a vcf file with a list of
variants in it and what i really want to
do is look at those variants and decide
which ones are interesting and perhaps i
don't know much about the patient and
perhaps i don't know what genes i might
be interested in but i do know that the
variants are of interest
and so what i can do here is i can
simply select and i have to make sure i
get the genome build correct
and i can choose my file
and
i can select here my vcf file and i can
just upload the list
now
this will then take and i think in as
far as about 60 yes 61 different
variants and i can see that most of them
are not in htmd but this one is and
again as you you know we're coming back
to this tgfb3
gene again
and this is the variant that i'm
particularly interested in and i can see
that straight away this is my disease a
disease causing variant
now
61 isn't too long a list have just to
have to scroll through but i can decide
to prioritize my list if i couldn't be
bothered to scroll right down to the
bottom because here i'm viewing this
with no prioritization so let's
prioritize
my
disease causing mutations and re-analyze
and that should put those at the top so
again it's really easy i can
straightaway find out this pathogenic
variant
so i find the batch search option one of
the easiest ways to really get the most
out of hdmd and this is only available
in the professional version
so as well as being able to upload a vcf
file which is what i tend to do most of
all you can also
upload
different file types perhaps if you've
got a list of db snip identifiers or a
list of
hdmd accession identifiers
that's also useful
and i should say that the
there is a limit to 500
terms that you can do at any one time
and i could have also set my
prioritization here um
one of the other things that's really
useful and it's quite a new feature in
hdmd professional
is the
ability to sort of limit the searching
as well to certain disease types so
um here i've been looking at lowercase
syndrome but i could have decided that i
only wanted to limit my search into
heart disorders or to
skin disorders so
this is quite a new feature within hdmd
but it does allow you
to be more specific and this is really
good particularly if you've got a little
bit of clinical information and a long
list of variants so we can start to
prioritize them based on
like a a disease concept as well
so one of the other ways of getting a
lot of information quickly as well as
doing the batch search you can do an
advanced search so i will just show you
that
and
again a nice way of doing it or to show
you the breadth of information available
is just to put in our favorite gene and
click start
and what this will do is this will
return me a list of mutations
and it will describe each of those
mutations in detail and give you the
reference from
where it was originally
described
now these mutations are
just listed here in this top table but
if i didn't want to scroll and i wanted
to go and perhaps look at those splicing
mutations i could click here and then i
will be taken to those splicing
mutations and i don't know if you
remember but the original table i showed
you contain where we did
where we viewed these splicing mutations
was very similar but here we've got this
extra bit of information where we can
really see where all of those bryce
sites
splice site mutations sit the location
the changes
the
substitution that's happened as well as
having the references
so
this advanced search is just a nice way
to really get um a more broader
range of information and summarized in a
very similar simple table format
so i hope today i've been able to show
you both um
uh with the
um
academic version
and the professional version the some of
the advantages of using hdmd
professional
or hmd academic
in your research
and i'm just going to pause here with
the demo and now switch back to my
slides
well thank you very much for watching
the demo
and hopefully that's shown you in a real
life scenario some of the points i
mentioned during the
slide
presentation so i'm just going to move
to my next slide to summarize
so
today during our our webinar we've
looked at hgmd both the free online
academic version and the professional
version and we've been able to see how
we can
search for genes
search for variants which is really what
hdmd is about
we've been we've talked about how we can
use the results to design panels how we
could even have the downloadable version
to improve
um
our machine learning models or even to
help us to understand our local
population genetics in a more detailed
way
and i hope that today i've been able to
give you some ideas where hdmd could
help you with your own research and if
you're not sure i would encourage you
perhaps to start off with the free
academic version which you can
go online now and and have a trial at
and then if that looks of interest then
please don't hesitate to contact us and
we'd be happy to show you in more detail
the professional version where you can
get the most up-to-date most relevant
content
and certainly you'll be able to improve
on
the search options within the htmg
professional tool
and so
i'm going to move to my last site and
finish here and i'd like to say thank
you very much for your attention today
and i'd be very happy to
stop here and take any questions
thank you dr burton for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you would like to ask please do
so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
how frequently is the hgmd database
updated
oh thank you well that's a very good
question and it's actually updated
quarterly
so you can be sure always to get get the
latest information about your variant
and from htmd
all right thank you dr burton let's see
we have another question
are there any other ways of accessing
hgmd other than the free or professional
version
uh yes yes there are we um we do have
other softwares for interpreting
variants and one is called collagen
clinical insight
interpret and that has hgmd included in
in it so if you've got a variant in your
sample that's contained in hdmd you'll
see that within our qci
or interpret software and that allows
you to actually link out to hdmd
and also
do other things in the way of
interpreting your variants such as
having the acmg guidelines and making a
clinical clinical report so yes there
are a couple of other options not just
having a standalone version of hdmd
thank you dr burton looks like we are
out of time for today
let's see
so thank you again dr ruth burton for
your time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor kiojin for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye